the jury
is now going to make a decision
on the smolette charges the case has
been handed off to them the trial is
over and as of eight minutes ago the
jury exited the courtroom in chicago to
begin their deliberations we don't know
how long those deliberations will last
it's conceivable we could get
a verdict today or this
evening but the arguments and the
cross-examinations and the testimony
that has all drawn to a close in the
closing argument from the defense
attorney and the team
representing jesse smallett
the
defense told the jury today
that the brothers right who were
allegedly hired by smallett to do the
fake hate crime
they were cast as quote smart and
sophisticated criminals the worst kind
of criminals
well i don't know if there's evidence
that they are
criminals
but if they are smart and sophisticated
criminals that would be a very dramatic
departure from their client jesse
smallette who would appear to be
a very stupid and unsophisticated
criminal
based on everything that we have heard
in the trial
during the closing argument one of the
defense attorneys for a smallet made
this point to the uh to the jury
arguing about his client what he's dumb
enough to go into obama's city and
pretend there's trump supporters running
around with maga hats give me a break
i think the obvious response to that is
why yes
yes he is exactly dumb enough to do that
because it's what he did
there's evidence of it
he cut a personal check to the brothers
for it he did a dry run with the
brothers on camera
he changed his story he lied to the
police
all of the evidence points
to the reality that indeed mr lawyer
your client is precisely that dumb
now this is interesting the national
black lives matter organization has put
out a statement
on all of this
on the smallett case
so that's what we needed
blm's take
on jesse
i'll give you one guess what the take is
before i read it to you i just want to
underscore something that i have said
before on the air and i've written
before as well when it comes to black
lives matter i am proud and happy to say
publicly and openly black lives matter
that proposition is important it is
correct
i understand why people say well how
about all lives matter and of course all
lives matter but the reason that black
lives matter is a powerful statement to
a lot of black people is that they have
felt through the years that black lives
have not counted as much or mattered as
much in the eyes of the law
is that true of our entire system are we
a systemically racist country no
is there some truth that we have fallen
short
of our values in this country
over time including more recently than
we would like to admit i think that
there is some truth to that
so i am supportive of black lives matter
the proposition
the idea
the statement
however i have been
consistently and vociferously opposed to
black lives matter the organization
and a lot of the things that they stand
for
things that they have published on their
website the destruction of the nuclear
family i mean all sorts of crazy
radical stuff
the violence and rioting done under that
banner
some of the horrible things that have
been said enchanted under that banner i
want no part of that and i think that's
an important distinction so with that in
place
the leaders of the the official leaders
of the formal black lives matter
movement writing at their website
blacklivesmatter.com they put out this
uh this statement
earlier today
actually was published it was posted
last night
and they have several different people
whose names are attached to this
they write in part in our commitment to
abolition meaning abolition of the
police
in our commitment to abolition
we can never believe police
especially the chicago police department
over jesse smallett a black man who has
been courageously present visible and
vocal in the struggle for black freedom
they go on to talk about policing being
an irredeemable institution which is
just
poisonous nonsense
but their position is because they're in
favor of abolishing the police which is
nuts
and crazy
dangerous
they cannot believe the police and the
evidence gathered by the police over
jesse smollette because he's black and
he's brave he's black he's not brave
he's a guilty idiot in my opinion and he
did a lot of damage it's the guy benson
show
you